he plays along with Pino and Rossi here
outstanding numbers in Iowa to start the
season here's a chance for geeky in Al loone
and a by flurry night here's a breakaway this
is not exactly the first shot you'd like to see
as a breakaway from the blue line but Mark Andre
flurry does not bite on the fake shot and makes
that save look very very easy around behind for
postr he had two goals Tuesday night in Boston
makoy with it marshan Pock up high to makoy postr
hammers one and scores a power play goal for
postak just 24 seconds into the man advantage
and the Bruins take advantage of the Capri
off penalty for a one Zer lead in shots last
year is leading the NHL in shots this year you
know anytime he gets the the puck in that area
he is not looking to pass the puck catches it
clean and blows it right over the top of Mark
Andre flurry maab boy at the top Anthony did a
great job of Merl settles it down for the Wild
and now moves out ler flings a backhander
on goal all Mark with a save Maran picks it
up got it through for Cole Coyle ahead to
De Brusque moving into the Minnesota Zone
debrus centers and what a save by flurry he slid
across to Rob marshan but now we're going to get
another penalty maroon through the neutral
zone on the far side and then got the hand
or the stick right in there on the hands great
play by debrus on the backside there and that
one looked like it just caught the outside of
the post looked like from up here that flurry
definitely got a pat on it but he did not caught
the outside of the post fast starts for Minnesota
lately scoring first and nine of the 12
games coached by John Hines is Bruins Club
the physical play and the speed that we
saw All Night Long at TD Garden yeah it's
it's there's not a whole lot of ice out there
for either team this time it's Boston in that
spot Lory out front and Omar has to make
the save on a short range shot by du his
speed in on the for check right there creates
a loose second effort with his stick to keep
that alive and Brandon doam gets a good shot
players hear everything especially today with
social media you knew you were going to get an
great effort early geeky with a shot saved by
flurry makoy fires pad save flurry Felino
off the end boards for Luchini
Luchini fires and a stick save
byar loo lost it to Middleton at Center
Ice Middleton down the boards with it
fires Tred to go short side and
allar hangs on exhausted Boston
Brewing players ler comes out of the
corner throws one on goal and a save by
allar yeah at least 50 you could have
played some golf today I would have
if it wasn't game day the brush with a
shot who was disgusted sure last night
rosi spins away from zaka back to faor his
shot got through pad save hmark Baldi into
the corner capriso back to baly capriso out
front one of Eric s capriso to rosi a shot
save all mark this is a little one I was
referring to all Mark able to get out on
top and square himself up didn't know where
the puck went Johansson in a shot right on
Save hmark final seconds of the power play
Bruins Killers I mentioned earlier third
best in the league for the season they've been
in a bit of a slump lately allowed six Power
Play Goals against in their last four games
prior to that they went 20 for 20 here's a
tip out front Eric up rebound they score
M rosi and the rookie has Minnesota even
well there is this huge fight around the front
of the net ecker's laughing at something on the
way back to the flyby there but it's loose Puck
line of scrimmage we need the puck wild come up
with it not a lot of hesitation one-timer
from Matt Baldi KN bodies going to the net
pucks and bodies to the net and Carlo happens
to knock that one in thought maybe Marco Rossi
had got it from up here I think ericon X's
going to get credit for that one right now
but again hanging on out around the front
of the net I thought Marco had a chance
to one time that one right away here's a
breakaway for geeki second long break and
both of them denied by flurry Eric theck ties
it and then flurry stops geeki for the second
time a great start to the second
for the wild COV just able to hold
the Zone goes down low to gagos keep to capris the
scores Carill capriso who's had overtime
winners in each of the last two games a
regulation goahead goal for Minnesota number
97 is starting to come alive little set play
at the top watch the hands here by capris off
getting the puck on top and then slowing his
skating down little give goal with goosi there
allmark not the best goenda from going side to
side and he's not able to react and Kil capris
off has a wide open net and right now the way
he's feeling it Anthony final game before the
holiday break here in St Paul wild trying to
make it six in a row on home ICE Felino with
a redirect at maroon with a Nifty little play
for a big man as he got some sweet Ms nice little
soft play Marcus Felino does a good job of being
heavy on his bottom hand here knowing is going
to get over top but that's just extra strength
and allar is able to producer who goes by
rigon is that close now he stays in the
miners Johansson holds his own
gagoski g r maroon to F on he
scores
Boston Bruin player Charlie Coyle just out of the
Penalty Box to make small short little plays look
at the patience here allows just enough time
for Marcus Felino to get inside position on
Carlo and there's that little 15t pass and
that right there is a very very important
goal in this game by two of the bigger men's
men in the National Hockey League and capriso
to Faber Baldi back to Faber and now capriso
fires off the post and then this is Carill
capriso off of the post there we've seen the
moving screen out it ahead to Frederick and
Mitchell dumps it into the Minnesota Zone
bagoan lost it back of the net a centering
pass and geeky scores he's been stopped on two
Lan breakaways by flurry but he beats him here
and it's 3-2 come from below the goal line down
here if you're not in great position defensively
it's such a bang bang play it's impossible
for the golender to pick up the puck you
just kind of hope it hits you and Morgan geeki
the great pass here by Heinen puts it right on
his forehand and he's able to get it off right
away and that one slips right through the pads
of the wild extend the win streak six
in a row in front of the home fans
and they closed the pre holiday
break portion of their schedule